peking apa aus dem deo dem feuerzeug und
drei holzbretter lucanet ich bekomme
heute seinen neuen video von der
beitritt einmal wieder videos und
sonstigen kram keinen wenden denen ich
dann in ein video annehme
ja
es ist format auf youtube ich meine
leute ihr kennt mich ich will mich nicht
weit aus dem fenster aber wer mega cool
wenn wir 17 trilliarden like schaffen
würden also lasst alle leica das ist
wirklich so mein lebensziel gerade
mitteln übermotiviert weil ich gerade
meine klausur fertig geschrieben habe
waren wir auch direkt an mit der ersten
einsendungen die wir relativ früh mit
dabei und hat im herbst luca reagiert
dabei bin sehr gespannt auf dieses video
jetzt gesagt ihr müsst mir da nicht nur
scheiße zu sein können doch etwas zu
sein wie die garantierte kinderhaus sie
irgendwelche talente hat oder ein
nachbar oder ein postkasten war 2
zechten welcher den ball nicht damit
gerechnet
wir schauen uns das noch mal an
b
auch nach dem zweiten mal anschauen kann
ich sagen es ist immer noch ein
verdammtes kaninchen dass ein ball vögel
[Musik]
ich mein ja gut ich habe in der tat
schon oft verstörenden content auf
youtube gebracht aber das jetzt
irgendwie echte die spitze gerade auf
dass das video glaube ich sogar von
einer webseite schon mal reagiert habe
nämlich to the world
[Musik]
und da habe ich vor einiger zeit mal
drauf reagiert der video hat ich weiß
nicht ob so eine million abrufe hat auf
jeden fall kommt auch relativ verstören
sag ich mal bei euch an weswegen leute
wenn ihr warcraft das normale website
reagiere weil diese ganzen videos sind
halt von dieser website bedingte stammt
ursprünglich von ihrer website anlass
sah man leichter und schreibt
in die kommentare weil dann weiß ich
okay wenn es wieder sind dass ich darauf
noch mal reagieren sondern mache ich das
morgen
davor dass er gerade gesehen habe yvonne
cottin wiener entstanden das war ein
treffen ob dem ich war in wien
organisiert vom network oder konnte
glock wertet die wir von euch auch
treffen ich habe das foto einfach mit
reingenommen weil ich das leben zwei
sachen zu sagen habe und verehrten ich
habe irgendwie 45 hätte kapp karton voll
mit geschenken von euch bekommen mit
keksen mit stofftieren mit allem
möglichen und zum gemeinden wie viele
von euch so jan luca verfolgten das mal
aus fakt die sache ich wollte das nicht
in dem video machen sondern bald auch
dem instagram livestream die sachen
werden an eine adresse in bielefeld
geschickt und dann wenn ich wieder dabei
meinen eltern binnen zwei drei wochen
dann wollte ich dann instagram spiel
machen und dann die sachen halt
auspacken und die beide sache nicht ganz
kurz sagen wollte damit bei der häfen
liefern konnte jeder sehen konnte weil
gehalt der viele leute standen und ich
habe zwar schon überzogen mit den
autogrammstunden halt trotzdem sehr
viele leute von euch nicht bedient kann
die leute die mich in nächster zeit noch
mal sehen wollen mit dieser sei
allgemein mal treffen möchten ich bin am
13.5 kennwort vor wie bei mick haig über
der im movie park und da könnte ich auch
treffen also ich bekomme jetzt kein geld
bürger so das zu sagen ich wollte nur
sagen dass ich auch da bin mit max und
jana und dann können wir uns treffen
hier musste ich sagen ich bin mega cool
dass in letzter zeit berlin locker
reagiert format was ich halt jetzt auch
mittlerweile wöchentlich hochladen weil
das euch auch mega gut ankommt da kommen
in letzter zeit weg ich werde viele
lachende kinder das video ich wirklich
denke ja okay da haben sich leute wie
mich hingesetzt haben sich diesmal
wirklich mühe gegeben ich feiere
natürlich die ganzen videos gegenseite
gemacht oder leute einfach kumpel oder
machen oder irgendwas natürlich torwart
ist halt einfach wieder sehe ich okay
ihr habt talent wieder einen body
browser
ich zeig euch jetzt an kater dass ich
dachte ich mache wirklich keinen tag
normalerweise klienten ich kann die
kamera nicht wunder machen
okay ich bin model ok ich muss gleich
raus bringen leute in sandwich gib mir
noch ein versuch meine damen und herren
[Musik]
da rede ich gerade von talentlosigkeit
meiner community und dann kommt von max
daher und sagt einfach läuft
ich hab voll viel wasser getrunken und
mir ist schlecht mir fällt nichts ein
richtig wahr sein
da macht man mal hier 23 episoden
wussten nicht drin vorkommt und dann
kommt er zurück mit der aussage fällt
nichts ein
leute wir müssen diese menschen retten
schreibt alle in die kommentare mir
fällt nichts ein leute ich hab eine
aufgabe in diesem video also schreibt
der partner beine komme fahre und das
hier sehen sollte bitte überreagiert
würdet nächste video locker reagiert
schon mal ein unternehmen schon ein
haufen einer richtig
lebensmittel weil dann können wir
vielleicht wieder so was los dreht wie
tomatensaft nur mit einem coolen lebens
wird hierfür halt okay diese person ich
mir diese videos zugestimmt hat ist also
gerade im supermarkt befindet sich dort
in der saft abteilung beim tomatensaft
im film den tomatensaft das hat man
schon gesehen das heißt ich hatte keine
großen voreiligen schlüsse oder so die
stadt ziehen möchte wir schon mal weiter
an
ich habe keine hobbys was kann ich
ändern hat bestätigen du bist in einem
supermarkt läuft dort rum und gegen alle
anderen leute oder in irgendeiner
gesetze eines supermarktes gästen dort
mich herum sachen als cop duo erreichte
er das komplette sortiment um nimmt den
tomatensaft und schmeißt den irgendwo
auf andere seite so sollte man einen
supermarkt auf jeden fall nutzen
[Musik]
leute heute das heutige video luca
reagiert ist wirklich die ganze
getrunken habe dort wo die not get paid
aber wohl weg wenn das bild also ich
trinke viel weil jeder mensch braucht
also werden also ich brauche jeder also
wenn wenn ihr wenn ihr mir frei also
pizza würde ich auch nicht sagen wollte
war das heutige video einfach so ein
typischer windig ist für diese komplette
super reagiert reihe weil sie hat feste
mitarbeiter ihnen neue auswahl in den
raum geworfen hat wir hatten über
bescheid wie du es dabei wie
beispielsweise einfach und kaninchen zum
beispiel den ball vögelt und wir hatten
leute dabei die talente hatten
beispielsweise sie sie kann klavier
spielen und vorhin konnte jemand gut
malen
also ich bin gespannt was das nächste
video sein wird zwei zuschauer von mir
die sich aus einem deo und ein feuerzeug
und drei holzbretter werfer gebraucht
haben aus dem bio dem feuerzeug und drei
holzbretter ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt
ein beschissenes video war oder ein
talent reiche video studiert auf jeden
fall ingenieurwesen weil sowas baut mich
jeder mit ja auch einmal ihr alt sein
das ist heute eigentlich los heute gehen
wir sogar nicht über die für normale
luca reagiert leiste durch die normale
videos reagierte huber reagiert oder
kommen wir wieder tolle video kein
gehzeit sowas wie heute beispielsweise
was bisher an 100 prozent videowerbung
talentfreie videos fallen volle video
unterhalt noch stellen mit irgendwas
gesehen habe dass der rede etwas
geschickter der markt hat ein video
geschickt haben wir haben noch
youtube-videos dabei derzeit wird über
den 100 prozent das ist jetzt ist ganz
ganz großes kino heute habt ihr bock
dass ich vielleicht mal mit heavy rain
let's play aufnehmen weil wir haben uns
ein spiel ausgesucht was halt vor sechs
sieben jahren rauskam oder sowas aber
sehr lustig ist und haben uns gedacht
dass nicht zeitabhängig also wenn ihr
bock habt dass ich mit remote play mache
oder videos anlass bleibt aber wir haben
uns jetzt lange nicht gewinnen
[Musik]
ich weiß dass ich früher einem videofilm
kollegen politik ausgeschlossen
im video und hat irgendwie drauf besitzt
und keine ahnung und da hat sie das wohl
irgendwie hergenommen und die meinte
sogar es widerlich dass täglich anhört
denn vivi ihren eigenen song raus
bringen würde dann kann ich das hier
wird jetzt auch die mindestens genauso
gut
[Musik]
respekt dass wir dort auf instagram
gegeben hast danke für 15 millionen aber
um die frage zu beantworten
ich finds komisch
in die kamera zu sprechen man muss nicht
immer darüber bewusst klein 2 und
youtube an jetzt sag ich mal weg so
etwas wie eine kamera sprechen und
blitzen locator sozialdaten gebraucht
sondern quasi hatte ich das jetzt in die
kamera sprechen weiß ich dass ich
irgendwann vielleicht millionen leute
sehen und das ist so ein bisschen das
beängstigende darum auf dem buch
bekommen ja ich glaube jeder mensch hat
und ich glaube auch nicht verwundert
mich ab lernen kann weil jeder mensch
diese stresshormone die nervosität unter
anderem befürworten können und derzeit
hervorrufen können also auch meinte
gerade ja lukas hat noch mit blogs
angefangen habe ich habe mich richtig
mit block wagen empfangen ich habe jetzt
nur weil ich ja in bienen vivaldi leise
mal geblockt also leute wenn ihr bei
kreditblogs like da er weil ich erlebt
in nächster zeit noch einiges ich bin
jetzt fast fertig mit dem studium
deswegen macht es einmal so ein neues
kapitel aufzuschlagen youtube mäßig also
blogs und so also ja wenn ihr bock auf
mehr habt dann lasst es mich wissen und
ich würde sagen wir kommen jetzt auch
mal zur letzten einwendung die mir
geschickt wurde
alles gläubiger blue caps das was jetzt
kommt meine damen und herren es euch
gefallen hat wie gesagt man leichter
schreibt in die kommentare auf dem meer
flossen wollten die kommentare reaction
ein wenig den morgen kultur live video
machen sollen schreibt in die kommentare
ob ich mit rewe aufleben soll hier bin
ich jetzt hier in smiley eingeblendet
wenn er da drauf sieg gekostet meinen
kanal abonnieren verpasst keine videos
mehr werde dadurch in bebra menz glaube
ich runter um findet ihr auch meinen
shop eingeblendet wo am ersten juni eine
neue sommerkollektion launischen wird
und hier unten ist ein anderes video
verlinkt
sorry das heute bisschen später kam das
video aber ich habe wie gesagt noch
klausur geschrieben